have you guys ever experienced what
thirst is not having to drink a single
drop of water for days these people have
our fridges are full of water please
give whatever you can for the sake of
allah so they can have something to
drink as your porn and sex addiction
affected your studies work marriage and
family relationship are you stuck with
feelings of guilt shame remorse and
despair or has your addiction progressed
from pornography to zinna well we're
here to tell you you're not alone itasca
is the place where muslim males and
females struggling with pornography
addictions can find recovery and freedom
assalamu alaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
yes you heard right kim kardashian is
willing to eat feces poo poo yes like
dave says dave chappelle says it's doo
doo baby
exactly she will go to that level to
stay young
whereas however the muslim woman
is the one that is oppressed they are
oppressed not the western woman who gets
her buttocks her lips her eyelids her
hair her skin her knees her toes
everywhere plastic surgery nothing is
left real it's all fake no they've got
freedom but the muslim woman is
oppressed let's study and look at this
problem this is a little bit careful i'm
going to touch upon this amazing book
which deals with the pandemic which is
greater than any virus which has come
into every single household of girls and
women made to feel ugly and uglier that
they cannot even leave the house without
makeup and they dare to tell us that the
muslim woman is oppressed because they
choose to obey the creator rather than
the creation because you're bound to
follow something regardless so the one
who choose the creator is oppressed but
the one who follows the creations um
never-ending list of beauty is not can
you imagine guys she's going down the
route willing to and people see this as
a joke it's not a joke i promise you if
she ate poo poo doo doo and she realized
that she stays young i promise you and
if she made her own product doo doo
product yeah whatever it may be okay and
said here you go and charge 39.99 or you
know what 99.99 i promise you every
single woman sadly even muslims who have
fallen to their sisters would even be
buying that product why because they
want to be beautiful
for the rest of their life they want to
and be young
but the point is this guys allah in the
quran promises that and when you don't
believe of course you're going to be
seeking in this life allah subhanahu wa
has promised the believing woman eternal
paradise beauty you want to be beautiful
eternally jannah
allah is promising you that for those
who believe your reward is going to be
there allah says in the quran so the
disbelievers which say in a nutshell
just paraphrasing guys not word for word
that they think that what they do an
evil disbeliever and a believer is going
to be the same on the day of judgment
are you for real
guys allah says never
because the woman the sister who
observes a hijab who stays away from
zina and even if she fell into dinner
she repents and fixes her weight a
sister who is trying to observe the
hijab a sister who
puts her creative before the creation
and puts the hijab in the correct way
and tries to keep her modesty and does
these actions do you really think that
she's going to be in the same category
on data on on on um
level with a woman who choose to show
whatever she shows whenever she likes
living whoever she likes eat whatever
she likes to wear
never never indeed one of allah's names
he's the most just yes and he would
never let your works go to waste so yes
you're bearing the heat and whatever it
may be but eternally you are going to be
in bliss inshallah because that is
exactly what you will deserve and that
is exactly the point of my video guys
let's look at some of the statistics it
is unbelievable let's go to this part
which i've named sad and hungry my
bookmarks yeah and this is what she said
they talk she's interviewing someone
called jamie and jamie laughs as she
says this a sad resigned resigned type
of love basically she calls the emphasis
on woman's thinness and career obnoxious
but still feels bound by this standard
she casually tossed out that she had
staffed herself for a period of time
during college going as long as she
could possibly go without eating
anything then if she felt like she was
about to pass out she would eat a yogurt
don't worry the muslim woman are
oppressed of course the muslim woman
oppressed yeah let's go to another one
and actress jennifer lawrence recently
called out those who fat shame in an
interview with yahoo ceo marissa meyer
lawrence asked what are you going to do
be hungry every single day to make other
people happy the western women are
realizing that look this is a standard
that they've given us we cannot reach
the system is rigged there is nothing
that we're going to do that's going to
reach it i encourage every single woman
to buy this book for god's sake yeah we
have this disease of beauty sick we are
doing anything and anything to look
young and beautiful and i believe this
is the reason why the western woman is
depressed suicidal anxiety and all these
mental disorders why because they have
to meet these standards that they could
never and they are made to feel uglier
and uglier whereas islam says no free
yourself from these shackles
and embrace yourself how you are because
you are a human being you are a woman
that has more to offer than your beauty
that's all i have to say do not forget
to check this video that i had a
discussion with a saudi girl who had a
similar question a very genuine sister
this will give a better idea of what i'm
talking about for now we'll let the kim
kardashian and the western world western
woman carry on eating pupu while we
stick to obeying our creator handle in a
dignified way and that the muslim woman
inshallah in paradise will have eternal
beauty and eternal youth
till next time assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi